so every profession has a code of ethics
doctors have a code of ethics the
Hippocratic oath lawyers accountants
journalists in fact part of a profession
is that there is a code of ethics and
museums and museum directors have an
association and a code and that code
says among other things that you can't
sell a work of art from your collection
and use that money to use to do
something else with it so for example
right now the Detroit Institute of Art
is battling the city because the city
wants to sell the art so that it can pay
pensions how does the director defend
himself how does how does he make a case
for this not to happen and who protects
him along with his board and that's
where a code of ethics comes in code of
ethics that is developed worked on by a
group of professionals changes over time
so now we turn to the Performing Arts
and for me it was a big surprise it was
a shock actually to hear and to think
about the fact that there really isn't a
code of ethics for the Performing Arts
of course I did some research just to
make sure let me give you an example and
this is a mundane example but being a
former pianist it struck me and that is
I was at a concert and the string
quartet was playing a Schubert quartet
and in the fourth movement the first
violinist turned to the second violinist
and gave a kind of a nod and the second
violinist gave a kind of a nod to the
cellist you get the idea and I was
thinking and I said what are they doing
I couldn't figure it out so they played
the piece and what they did or what they
didn't do was they didn't play the
repeat of the first part of this
Schubert quartet now the general
audience they probably didn't know as a
as a musician I knew is it a big deal
it's not what Schubert intended so is
there some reason is there some things
that we can use
to guide to help us understand what's
right and what's not okay that's a
mundane example and lots of people break
that a Brut so code of ethics about
playing repeats when I play the piano
now of course I'd play all the repeats
that are necessary take that a little
further though into the realm of what
does a producer do when thinking about
what can be and what can't be done a
couple of years ago Diane Paulus is a
wonderful director and producer in
Boston did a version of porgy and bess
one of the classic American operas
everybody knows porgy and bess and some
of it is sad and some of it is you know
to some people a little boring and Diane
Paulus decided to do a completely
different version of porgy and bess she
decided to make it more modern which is
fine she decided to change the ending
which is questionable she decided to
change some of the music now you know
I'm a purist this really bothered me of
course so the question is can Diane
Paulus do that of course she can do it
but can she call it porgy and bess it's
now it played on Broadway for a season
there's a cast recording and in the
future will there be an understanding by
a generation who think that this is what
porgy and bess is okay so I don't want
to be pedantic about this but but my
point is that over and over again there
are questions that every profession has
that the members of the profession have
not discussed to say what's right what's
wrong and argue about sure but there's
no basis there's no moral basis it gets
a little more complicated there was a
production in Berlin and a Berlin opera
house of a Mozart opera called in
demonium and this producer opera
director in Berlin and in Berlin you
know they do kind of outlandish kinds of
opera decided to do
very outlandish production in which
among other things Muhammad was inserted
into the Opera it wasn't in the Opera
and took the place of another character
and for some people for some Muslims it
seemed like a sacrilegious thing to do
and there was a big protest and the
question is does the head of the Opera
Company say the director has the right
and the ethical right to do what he
thinks is right or does that person give
in to public appeal so the answer is who
knows and the answer is also we don't
know because there isn't this kind of
set rule if a doctor is faced with an
ethical choice they turn to their code
of ethics if a museum director is faced
with an ethical choice they turn to a
code of ethics if a performing arts
director or a string quartet leader or a
producer on Broadway is faced with what
might be considered by some an ethical
choice they have nothing to fall back on
so to speak what we need are a group of
professionals who are in the theater who
can at least discuss it who can set the
beginnings of a fundamental of an
ethical decision or an ethical
philosophy